hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm going to explain
how the bank of England are absolutely
destroying and killing the property
market right now the housing market is
on its knees property investment is very
tough right now and if you're anything
like me you've got a lot of houses
there's some of my properties that were
making me nice money I was making a
couple hundred pound a month now I'm
losing money on and it's the bank of
England's fault so base rate going up
has screwed us all and in this video I'm
going to talk about how that's happened
why house prices are dropping right now
my predictions on the property market
and how if you're super smart and
prepared to work hard you could actually
profit from this crisis so if you like
the sound of that like the video because
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this right now
I'm gonna do this once take good notes
like the video and let's get cracking so
firstly what the heck is going on base
rate has gone up that is let me explain
how this works so the bank of England
okay they basically print money now
don't take my opinion on this go do your
own research research quantitative
easing what does it mean it's when the
bank of England effectively prints money
and then when they print money or just
add zeros to the screen what do they do
with that money they loan it out to who
to the other Banks the smaller Banks and
they loan it out well a year ago they
were loading out 0.1 percent so they'll
print money they'll learn it to the
other banks at 0.1 the money loaned out
from the big Banks like the bank of
England to the smaller Banks
um the engine that has gone up it was
0.1 base rate keeps going up and up and
up it's now four percent what that means
is that means that when you're getting
money like a normal loan a mortgage from
say Lloyd's Bank from Halifax you're
borrowing money
that's borrowed so they borrowed it to
lend it you now they were borrowing it
at 0.1 now they're borrowing it at four
percent so how much they're going to
charge you five percent six percent
seven percent we had properties didn't
we Amanda how much we were paying like
what three four hundred pound a month
now we've been 600 600 and what's the
rent 500 right so we were paying 300 on
the on the interest because base rate
was low interest interest rates were low
now we're paying 600. the rent's only
500 what does that mean that means that
the property sucks now now it's not an
asset it's a liability so it's gone a
little bit dark now it's Doom and Gloom
message I think that's why so
what's happening now is people can't
afford
to buy houses and the reason they can't
afford to buy houses is because
the interest rate is going to be so high
the rent's not going to cover the
mortgage payments or if people are
looking to buy a house to live in
previously with interest rates at maybe
three percent they're thinking okay I'll
move into the house I'll be paying three
percent that means I'll be paying per
month 500 pounds a month that makes
sense now if you buy a house with
interest rates doubling you're not going
to be paying 500 pounds a month you're
gonna be paying a thousand pounds a
month what does that mean that means
that people can't afford to buy houses
right now because people can't afford to
buy houses because the bank of England
put their rates up so that all rates
have now gone up now people can't afford
to buy houses so what are they doing
they're not buying or they're buying
cheaper so house prices are falling
right now so that's what's going on
that's the problem I want to talk to you
not just about the problem but I also
want to talk about the opportunity first
thing I'm going to say about the problem
is this in the same way that house
prices have suddenly started dropping
it happened almost overnight estate
agents technology change fast the state
agents were saying I'd ring up to book a
viewing and they'd say oh there's 27
people already interested in this house
okay now I'll ring up to book a viewing
and then stage will say yeah man come
and see it they're open to offers the
Market's falling five months in a row
the property Market has dropped we
haven't had a house dropped this fast
since
2008-2009 so
in the same way the house prices are
dropping fast they could very quickly
settle in it might take it might be in
six months it might be in two years but
in the same way that they fall fast they
also shoot up fast because I can
remember I was buying houses in 2008
2009 and I can remember when house
prices were dropping and then suddenly
bang they suddenly shot back up I mean
in London
2011. between 2011 to 2017 a lot of
houses doubled in value so in the same
way that they so if you're if you're
there thinking like oh man I'm not going
to buy them in a weight how house house
prices are drop in everyone's scared
everything's bad I'm just gonna wait it
out
the problem is people that wait it out
by the time you go oh man hashbrush is
going up it would too late
because right now the opportunity I
believe because right now estate agents
are giving banging deals so there's
three opportunities that I see in the
market right now number one is getting
cheap houses okay yes house prices are
dropping but the fear that they will
continue dropping more is so strong in
people's minds that people are prepared
to sell really cheap I I put an offer on
a property uh for 450 000 pounds in High
Wickham about
three months ago and they said
absolutely no and then they ended up
selling it for 500 Grand
the estate agent called me yesterday and
said the buyers pulled out
they would accept your offer now and I
said well I can't do more than 4 15.
415.
and now they've got to think about it so
now is a good time to get cheap banging
deals so if you want to buy cheap
especially if you know how to push the
value up and then refinance like if you
want to buy refurbished refinance okay
and what that is is that's when you buy
a house
right cheap you push the value up and
then you refinance it and you you use
the added value the theoretical Equity
you use to leave in as the deposit is
how you can recycle money and
effectively snowball your portfolio
massive this is the time that people are
doing that these are the months when
when property whenever when everything's
Rosy everyone's talking about how great
everything is well that's when the rich
people are just waiting
so the poor people right now are waiting
the poor people are saying well let me
just wait and see what happens the rich
people are getting in and getting deals
so that's the first thing I'll say
second thing I want to talk about is
buying houses because everyone's scared
there's so many people right now
negative equity so there's people that
bought a house let's say two years ago
for two hundred thousand now the value
is 170. but they only put in a 10
deposit
so they bought it for 200 and they've
got like 180 000 pound mortgage because
they just they got a Residential
Mortgage they put down 10 percent
so their mortgage is 180 Grand and now
the value of the house is 170 Grand now
they're freaking out now they want to
sell but they can't sell because their
mortgage is more expensive than the
value of the house that's called
negative equity that's called an upside
down house
and there's thousands of people right
now going into negative equity there's
thousands of people that want to sell
the house but can't because they're
trapped because they've got no equity in
the house so even if they sell it for
100 of the true market value today that
isn't even have to pay off the mortgage
what do you do with those houses
you buy them on a purchase this option
agreement
the stuff I've been preaching for the
last five years on YouTube now it's time
to actually go do it now I'm just gonna
implement
because there's thousands of people that
are scared that are in negative equity
where you can say well I tell you what
your house is worth 180 and you want to
sell it but your mortgage is 180.
so why don't you just give me the house
and I'll take on the debt
she basically just get in the house
taking on the debt paying a one pound
option fee
and there's people that will do it
because they're so scared of the market
what are you now gonna do well that's my
third opportunity the third thing I want
to talk to you about some of our houses
we're having we're losing money on right
now like the one that you just spoke
about in London it sucks some of our
houses that we're beginning to lose
money on I mean luckily we fixed our
rates didn't we've nearly the whole
portfolio but some of the houses
we're having to be more creative now
we're like man our mortgage payments are
a thousand pounds a month the rent's
only 900 damn what are we gonna do so
what we're doing is we're having to turn
them into short stay let's
and shorts day let's serviced
accommodation is when you rent your
property out instead of renting out to a
normal tenant on an AST contract you
rent it out on booking.com on Airbnb and
I tell you what the tax advantages and
the cash flow is
here's the thing right whenever there's
a crisis and you're forced to be
creative I actually you end up doing
things and you're like damn why wasn't I
doing this two years ago so some of our
portfolio we've turned onto short stay
let's and we're making crazy crazy money
my brother's got a house in Lichfield
it's fully booked up he's renting it out
for about 150 pound a night
four four and a half thousand pounds a
month that's how much he's rented it for
if he rented it as a normal single it
he'd get barely a thousand pounds so
he's getting four times as much
because he's renting out on short stay
let's and that I think is the is the
opportunity right now sure stay let's
lease option agreements banging deals so
what I would say is if everyone's scared
that's when you should be greeted that's
what Warren Buffett says I mean
everyone's greedy you should be scared
yes we're in a crisis yes the bank of
England have messed up house prices
everything's dropping and base rates up
yes you need to be more creative but if
you're prepared to get creative and put
the work in now or everyone else is
waiting
then you're gonna get rich this year